well austerity has caused so much damage
for so many communities not just in ways
where I represent but communities
throughout the United Kingdom and I've
said that I would work with our
colleagues in the SNP and any greens
that are elected in England in order to
end austerity to properly invest in our
communities and to rebalance power and
wealth throughout these islands we say
that far much far too much power and
wealth has been concentrated in London
and around the southeast and people
throughout these islands need more of a
share it's I'm thinking you refer to the
SNP there because your values that
sounds similar to many of theirs and yet
in Scotland the SMP are polling
incredibly well as you'll know about
fifty percent at the moment roughly a
plaque on we not achieving that same
levels of success as far as the polls
concerned the latest one I've seen shows
that you're pulling around eleven
percent in Wales why do you think you're
not seeing the same kind of breakthrough
we haven't had our breakthrough yet the
SNP had their breakthrough in 2007 when
they first formed a minority government
they've managed to show that they they
can lead a government well and they've
built up trust in that government and
that support has increased from their
plight Camrys time will come I'm
noticing already that the numbers of
people who are responding positively to
the messages that we're putting forward
is growing so I'm confident that we will
see an increase in our support as time
goes on but of course then the the
figure that you refer to is in reference
to a Westminster election and we have
different elections and we pull
differently depending on the election
that we're talking about well yes let's
talk about a Westminster election for
the SMP as well but what then is your
ambition for this election how many MPs
you hope to achieve where we have three
at the moment and I've said that I'd
like played Camry to have its best-ever
Westminster election result the maximum
number of MPs we've ever held at one
time is four so but there are the three
seats that we hold and there are another
three seats that we've got excellent
candidates in working hard so we we
should increase our
a number of seats hopefully well if you
achieve that target you managed to get
four MPs they could be crucial in
helping form a new government if the
polls are correct and we are infra for
hung parliament you have already ruled
out doing a deal with the Tories why so
quick to make that judgment before even
their manifesto came out because I'm a
Democrat and people in rears have never
given the tourism and it to rule over
them and I don't think that they are
likely to give the Tories that mandate
in this election I either so we've said
you're prejudging what voters think
though aren't you well it looks as
though the the voters are going to
decide on a hung parliament that neither
of the two main parties have done enough
to convince them that they deserve their
trust or a mandate but there is a strong
feeling in Wales about the whole
question of austerity and cats and the
way in which the tory-led government has
driven those cuts through from an
ideological perspective is something
that many people in where's find hard to
accept do you think having heard that
manifesto that you could have made the
wrong call on that you could perhaps
work with these people they're calling
themselves today after the party of
working people we've heard about them
extending the right to buy to social
housing tenants 30 hours of free
childcare a week for working parents
promised that tax allowances will rise
to ensure the minimum wage is tax-free
does any of that sound appealing to you
I'm sure that most working people will
raise their eyebrows at that description
of the Conservative Party that's not
where most people see the Conservative
Party they see them as the party
representing the privileged and yes
there are a number of Giveaways in their
manifesto and of course they haven't
explained exactly how they're going to
meet their commitments in terms of the
cuts in light of all these giveaways but
you know the tit let's take the question
of the social housing the house in
pledge that they've made today if they
went ahead and sold off the the numbers
of housing that we have the houses in
social housing then that would leave
fewer housing housing options about four
people so that's a problem what about
labour will you do a deal with labour
and if you will what red lines would you
lay down I've said that we would work
with
a Labour government but not a Labour
government that wanted to implement Tory
policies so the question of austerity
and cuts is key you heard the manifesto
though well yes and they've made a
number of commitments that we would find
difficult to live with like for example
we know that they are open to renew in
trident replacement and that is
something that flight camry mps would
never ever support so is that a red line
that's a red line as it trident well I'd
prefer not to talk in terms of red lines
because when you go into a helpful for
the electrode isn't it well I think it's
had for more helpful to talk in terms of
principles and priorities and Trident is
an important priority for us and play
Camry MPs would never sign up to a deal
which involved then voting for trade and
replacement okay bullion would we
appreciate your time tonight thanks very
much a day to thank you